let's get into your questions for the week.
What's a deal, Blake?
Breaker David, when voting where you simply
will not vote for someone if they have a certain
our
view for or against something or do a certain
thing.
So I'll answer this.
It's important that we differentiate between
litmus tests, deal breakers, and sort of being
like a single issue voter because these are
all different things.
I've talked before about the way in which
litmus tests can be damaging to getting the
worst person out of office or preventing the
worst candidate from winning.
When litmus tests are used to divide a movement
in a way that makes it fail to do what the
bigger goal sort of is.
Um, what, what I think it's damaging to do
is to go from thinking about deal-breakers
in a reasonable way to litmus tests that are
sort of out of context and sometimes self-defeating
to the type of single issue mentality that
can almost make you a damaging participant
in the system in the context of achieving
broader goals.
Also, I think that what is a deal breaker
in a primary election can be different than
what is a deal breaker in a general election.
Uh, and I think, you know, the, the centrist
establishment Democrats like Joe Biden, the
latest version of Pete boot edge edge, because
in 2018 his rhetoric was far more leftist,
Amy Klobuchar, et cetera.
I would still vote for them in the general
election.
So I think that that's important to consider.
Often for me, the things that feel like deal
breakers where I just become so disgusted
with a candidate that I just won't even consider
them the sort of WTF moments.
It's social issues.
And what's interesting about that is that
economic issues are the ones that are much
more impactful to a greater number of people
in many ways.
But when I find out, like if you think gay
people shouldn't be married, uh, that's a
drastically different thing than we disagree
with the top marginal tax rate would be.
Now, interestingly enough, what the top marginal
tax rate is and the government revenue that
comes from that and what can be done with
that money may actually impact way more people
than whether a candidate believes that gay
and lesbian couples should or shouldn't be
able to get married.
But at this point it is so whacked to me to
still be saying, I'm really against, uh, two
guys getting married or two women getting
married.
There's no sensible reason for that.
We, there is debate about what the top marginal
tax rate should be.
Now, if you want to come to me and say the
rich should pay no taxes and the poor should
pay huge taxes, that's so stupid that maybe
it would become a deal breaker.
But there is a, uh, there is a debate to be
had about where the top marginal tax rates
should be and what the tax brackets should
be.
And it's not a deal breaker in that cartoonish
way.
Somebody who believes the Bible should be
the law of the land.
That seems like a deal breaker to me and it's
hard to imagine someone just coming out and
saying it.
It's usually intimated or implied through
positions on abortion or gay marriage or,
or whatever else.
You can't think climate change is just a fake
hoax, right?
That that's a deal breaker.
You could disagree about how we should deal
with climate change.
You can disagree about how we should deal
with carbon carbon credits versus, you know
what, we could have that debate, but you can't
think that it's made up.
That is a deal breaker.
But really it's all context.
We've talked on the program before about how
it's really important to know what our principles
are, but those who just focus on the principals
often are unable to actually have pragmatic
conversations and make pragmatic decisions.
When you have to apply the principles to the
real world.
Eventually you're choosing between two or
a few people in terms of who's likely to actually
represent you in a candidacy.
The principles are important as a starting
point and eventually you would try to apply
those principles to the positions of the candidate
and concessions likely have to be made.
And so I think it's great to understand what
are the deal breakers for you.
You don't want to go over into sort of toxic
litmus test world where you end up damaging
your own movement and eventually you almost
always are going to have to make some compromises
on whoever it is you choose to support.